foreign
[Music]
yeah you know it is what it is and also
uh uh I'll be on tour I'm on date you
know I just I'm getting my budget back
back and forth but I have a bunch of
different uh tour dates coming up I'll
be in Pueblo Colorado I will be in Salt
Lake City in Boise Boise not Boise
tricked you Tucson Arizona uh Colorado
Springs for some reason Charlotte North
Carolina Knoxville Tennessee Little Rock
Arkansas for some reason Memphis for
some reason Nashville Calgary Edmonton
Ottawa Montreal Hamilton Pittsburgh
Cleveland Detroit Orlando Fort Myers
Florida for some reason Richmond
Virginia but but be more as I like to
call it Philadelphia and uh reading
which is on sale now a lot of people
have been asking about that because I
said it I leaked it it's the best kept
secret oops I guess that I just leaked
it but that was uh reading is going to
be in Pennsylvania so it's it's live now
but uh go to chrisley.com for your uh
tickets and uh you know without further
Ado this is the next episode of
congratulations
crazy
[Music]
so guys what the Frank dude we gotta uh
incorporate that a little bit you I'm
done with swearing uh I got a kid now I
got two kids now you know and uh I just
got back from the road uh for in um I
was in Columbus Ohio and Cincinnati and
when I went
I was going I was talking to somebody
who's an Ohio native and he said man
Columbus is cool Cincinnati
trash
not what I said not what I say this is
what I heard before I went okay
you know and I'm just kind of soaking it
in I don't know if you know I don't
really know much about Cincinnati I've
been there once been to Columbus maybe
two times you know
um and uh went to Columbus guess what it
was fine went to Cincinnati and it was
absolutely absolutely it was absolutely
banging
so the guy it doesn't know
and that's okay because we all have
different opinions right we do we all
have different opinions and that's fine
but let me tell you something dude the
first time
look the shows were of course the shows
were banging right because you know
white guy if I fill the seats people
[__] sit down they don't sit down for
too long because they got to jump up
because they get so exciting the [__]
start climbing to go oh yeah I guess
um Columbus uh
they go like this my crew uh Denny uh
well actually no they weren't even with
us at that point
um but uh Sam camera guy uh my buddy who
uh rose with me does all the the tour
Vlogs by the way uh and um
Chris Marco my buddy came with me and
then also David Sullivan came with me
the fat guy so we we David's like hey
man let's do the [__] by the way uh
David Sullivan came with me he's an
actor he's in stuff you gotta watch him
on Fatal Attraction watch Fatal
Attraction on Paramount plus uh it's a
it's a good show I'm into it for a show
look I'm gonna be honest for sure don't
talk donkey balls but then I got into it
right I want there to be more of David
he's good I wish it was a me it was the
lead guy first episode suck donkey balls
and then it got good okay episode two I
was like I don't know episode three I'm
in but what does Paramount plus do dude
they make you wait every week for a new
episode so I'm pissed right because
remember when they invented streaming
that took that all out and now streaming
is going back to oh we're gonna leak it
out once a week and I'm just like dude
streaming lasts for like [__] five
years and now they're going back to
every week is a new episode like I had
to deal with this [__] with uh uh uh the
[__] zombie one that everyone's
saying is the next
The Last of Us with Pedro Pascal
um so David Sullivan is an actor he's a
successful actor loves coming on the
road with us just likes doing it you
know why he's running for something we
don't know what but he's absolutely
running from something okay he loves
you know what he loves
uh moving and shaking right like he's
just like uh I you'll just be like dude
uh Skee-Ball all right man I found two
play I found two places and you're like
how I just looked it up you're like I
mentioned it point five seconds ago
you'll be like uh uh bumper cars I man
there's a place it's not 25 minutes ago
so anyway
uh we do this
and we get there and by the way but
before I even get into that part this
what we did with exploring the cities uh
David I always say how he's fat okay
he's that's just the joke I don't even
know why I started saying it me and my
brother started saying it uh
he's just a 46 year old guy it's there's
no he's just a guy if you think of a guy
who's 46 and then
his a guy's body who's 46 that's David's
body
guy he's got guy body right
you know
is he shredded no he's got guy body
right so so he's
got his guy body the whole time right
and I talk about how fat he is and [__]
like that and he's like do you cut do
you say I'm fat on your podcast I'm like
why because people [__] comment on my
Instagram
and so so I say to him uh so so he's
doing he just comes and he goes and he
works the merch booth just because he
wants to right because running from
something dude okay but he's like I just
worked him and he'll be texting me man
I'm sweating out here I got some water
thing and uh dude so he says uh so he's
out there does the marching and he says
man people come up to me and he said hey
hey you're not you're not fat
and as he says you say I'm fat a lot and
I do oh yeah all the time bro you got
guy body dude I know people say Dad bot
I don't like that because Dad bought to
me evokes like kind of a little bit
fatter guy body is worse like guy body
is worse because it's on the way to fat
and it's like figure it out you know
what I'm saying like every nobody not
everybody could have a [__] movie set
on the back of their shoulders right
they can't they can't
they can't they can't carry camera crew
like your boy does right
everybody's [__] tummy can't be a
[__] mini ski slope Black Diamond
level right it can't
right can everybody's just have
striations no
David's got guy body so it's all good
and
um
so anyway he does this thing where he's
like hey man
you ever beat on those lime scooters and
I was like what
truth be told I did lime scooters once
uh in uh parking lot of Coffee Bean and
Tea Leaf and I put one foot on it and I
hit the [__] you know the just a
little bit early and it just shot out
from under me I almost fell down I
didn't but so we can't really count it
as an accident but I'm like oh I'm never
touching these lime scooters again
uh
uh and he uh he was like let's do it
we're in Columbus Ohio we had the whole
day I'm like all right [__] let's try
it dude and um
we did it
and it's not hard dude
lime scooters guess what dude it's not
hard
and they're all [__] over the
everywhere so we hopped on the lime
scooters and dude
like honestly
Just Wind in the hair just dude and I'm
doing immediately doing the thing where
you're holding it and then you're moving
the legs and you're doing it like this
and I'll tell you something dude I
actually looked pretty [__] cool man
and nobody could take that from me okay
I look pretty [__] cool weaving in
and out of the streets of Columbus Ohio
I love that there were people in
Columbus Ohio that didn't know I was in
town for a show and saw me [__] Race
by
you know
[__] yeah dude it felt so euphoric and
then I realized something about myself
people say I don't like doing things oh
yeah you don't like doing things though
it's not the things I don't like doing I
don't like being around too many people
because also there was a Cinco de Mayo
[__] thing in that was Cincinnati
right
and dude it was
they were just by the way Cincinnati how
the [__] does it have the Mexican food
was good in Cincinnati crazy weird
because it's not even close to Mexico
and there's like no Mexicans there
probably are but
um and I was around too many people and
I don't want to be but then we got those
lime scooters and we did lime scooters
in [__] Cincinnati and we banged it
and it was so dope dude and now I'd like
to do honestly I'm gonna drive down to
Hollywood Boulevard just pick up a lime
scooter leave my car and just [__] go
all around the place I'm gonna take
pictures with the [__] uh Spider-Man
on Hollywood and Highland just zip out
dude
I [__] honestly those lime scooters
are dope I don't even know I mean this
isn't a uh commercial but
you know I rolled around the city I was
I was out for like two hours it costs 11
bucks dude so you know
um
those shows were amazing Cincinnati was
great
um and uh Columbus was great
bro you know what actually happened I
take this [__] drink called Magic
mind and it's great okay love magic mind
and uh I take it with my coffee
and I'm not getting paid to say this by
the way I'm not [__] being paid to
say this but I took this drink
because my friends like you gotta try
this magic mine and I'm like first of
all it has the word magic in it
go [__] yourself and he says just try it
I said okay what do I do what is it and
he says it's just like got mushrooms and
[__] in it make you feel good
uh natural all-natural and I'm like okay
and then he says you take it with your
coffee and guess what you don't have to
drink coffee the rest of the day you're
[__] you're you're at a level of
like
activated but not jittery and I'm like
okay
took it dude
alert City
alert City I was alert like a
[__] I was alert I was
practically a [__] private
investigator the whole day I was just
like huh huh
and it's that big and I and I took up my
coffee didn't drink any coffee the rest
of the day dude alert City and I'll tell
you what
um I didn't bring it so I've been
drinking for like two weeks didn't bring
it to Columbus and Cincinnati and I
suffered from it and yes now it doesn't
have it doesn't have uh the kickback
[__] like you you can stop taking it
whenever you want it's not like a drug
or anything but yeah man it absolutely
was killer magic mind
um
so need to bring it on the road and you
can carry it on the plane because it's
like that big little [__] keychain
shits but it's cool man anyway
Sensational I um will say that uh I
learned about magarap
because I was watching I'd be watching
Vice than a [__] Vice is pretty
pretty Vice is like they they put out
good [__] on their YouTube channels but
also like anyone that works for vice I
bet would be so [__] annoying at like
the dinner table you know what I'm
talking about
they'd just be like we sat down with
some turkey
we sat down with a family in some turkey
it might not be your typical family it
might not be your typical turkey but let
me tell you something it worked
but anyway I I watched one video on Vice
I don't know what these people are are
some people are just in with YouTube you
watch one video and then all of a sudden
your homepage is just [__] it's vice
vice vice everything's Vice so I saw
this one thing on Maga rap which I
didn't know was a thing it's a thing
dude Mega rap
is basically it started with Trump
and these dudes uh
uh do a rap about Trump they remember
about Trump and they rough about
um
look like look at this this is a wrap
here we go uh who's it oh this guy says
the worst music ever made you know
who's the guy uh
uh foia
blow that's it
dude I was [__] farting on the plane
today pretending like I had no idea who
it was I was dude oh I'm sorry
I don't know man is that bad it is bad
right
this is called Teflon Don
oh here's here we go here we go wait
wait if I play this I'll probably get
demonetized because if I [__] Teflon
Don major new developments involving
former president Donald J Trump Trump's
saying today he expects to be arrested
on Tuesday and is calling for protest
I heard the fans wanna lock up Uncle
Trump yeah
Uncle Trump dude
uh also I love Maga
man hey it's over
the thing about this music is you gotta
[__] in this guy's name is
Forgiato blow
but dude here's the thing about this is
um
you this guy has to make
he has to do it so quickly when the
thing happens because it's like news
will happen to be like gotta make a song
about this like they call Kyrie Irving
is that the guy's name that got because
he tweeted that thing about against the
Jews right that was him
and he was like uh this is [__] that
they're you know they're they suspended
him or whatever and then he they were
like um
he said to him he said he was like
this guy photo blow was like I love that
Kyrie Irving did that and he didn't
apologize and then they started making a
song as they were making the song Kyrie
Irving apologized and the guy's like yo
we can't make this song anymore because
he bitched out and the other guy was
like yeah but you know he didn't take
the vaccine so I'm still kind of on my
Kyrie Irving [__] I'm just like oh
but uh
make
um
it is crazy man that uh Trump still has
his [__] tentacles out there in
people but I know by the way I'm not
talking no hate on no no hate on nobody
dude
Joe Biden
no hate on nobody they're all every
politician is corrupt
oh yes every post is just corrupt yes
dude but it's okay where would you
rather live where they [__] cut off
your hand for stealing no
you can steal whatever you want nowadays
and they won't even lock you up so
they'll just be like okay now
um
I'm feeling I'm feeling good I'm happy
at the uh
what's this here
what's this here uh oh yeah this was the
craziest thing that has happened in a
long time and I bet we'll have to bleep
this out but
this is the Oakland A's announcer
I you know what I'm just gonna play it
first of all the gun left looks like a
muppet but here it is we had a
phenomenal day today totally totally
normal
totally normal so far we had a
phenomenal day today and you're just
sitting in sitting down buckling up you
go dude I'm gonna check out the A's
and the best thing about the A's is it
brings people together
you know baseball is America's pastime
[__] man
they had they had a phenomenal day I'm
gonna have a phenomenal day so here we
go here we go we're gonna play it again
we had a phenomenal day today that's
amazing Museum
UPS
we had a phenomenal day today
and Arthur Bryant's Barbie
dude dude
what a plug for Arthur Brian's barbecue
by the way
[Music]
you know I'm gonna plug you because we
went out we went to uh Arthur what is it
Arthur [__]
and Arthur Brian's Barbie Arthur Brian's
I'm gonna plug your uh thing so that's
great oh yeah just listen to it
a guy from Arthur Barnes
oh my God
it's Negro League also hey black people
you tricking us you know somebody you
know them old guys are gonna [__] this
up
he said the n-word League a guy yeah you
say it
hey guy you say it in private Lots
or maybe not because here's the thing it
might be now I know a lot of people are
like oh [__] it you can tell he says a
lot [__] him and you don't know if
that's true he could have a brain fart
could be a total guy dude I'll tell you
right now I never say the n-word like
just straight up I never say in private
I never say with my friends never say it
as a joke and I just don't say it it's
not part of my vocabulary if I was doing
the the thing right
and I'm gonna say oh here it comes in my
head like we had a fantastic day today
oh God I gotta say the Negro League
thing I hope I got to say it right oh no
if I don't and then as I'm saying as I'm
saying negro I say whoopsie and I'm
thinking negro so much gotta say negro
can't say uh and then if you think at
the last second before you're about to
say it can't say uh can't say negro
gotta say oh and you say and you go oh
oh for [__] this is this guy shouldn't
I don't know if this guy should be fired
I get that you have to kind of maybe
suspended which is what they're doing
but this is who has to be fired the guy
next to him
who just goes like this
hey guy
how did you not go on live TV the guy
says the n-word you just go you don't
just go oh
that would have been me dude here's me
next to him we had a phenomenal day
today
oh and Arthur Bryant oh [__] man
oh I have nothing to do with that this
guy's made a wow
oh
so that sucks for this guy right look at
this somebody writes you guys are so
soft it's an accident
and then somebody says blacks look for
any reason to flip out
the worst reason
hey
like this is so bad you know oh just
come on
here we go rolled off his tongue too
easy that's the right that's it there
you go
um
I mean this is just
look at this is just the devolvement of
like when you just go to you by the
fourth comment everyone is just like and
that's why I don't use [__]
Frigidaire you pieces of [__] you know
how to get the refrigerators
oh
wow pretty crazy
yeah wow well
the king coronation you know
stop it just stop it dude
Grand
dude every outfit is a hundred and
ninety thousand dollars
so slow dude
just so boring hey if you watch the
king's coronation you [__] suck
you're boring huh you're just straight
up so boring look at the music sucks
dude
this is like the music that should
happen when you walk into Universal
[__] Studios
[Music]
oh dude I here present you like get out
of here with your dry [__] you know come
to you King Charles oh it's so [__]
I hear present to you King Charles
why are you getting coronated now you're
undarted King
wherefore all you who have come this day
singing
I here presents to you
[Music]
I'm gonna drive
service are you willing to do the same
God save King Charles morons
dude this is a [__] Adam Sandler
movie waiting to happen you know I would
say I'm just like yes Abby the king you
know
who
yeah uh yeah I'll be the king can I
bring my cat you know
there'd be a cat in it moving the walls
God this sucks to have to do this you
know the way they walk wind-up toys
dude this sucks oh my God bro and they
get you too they get you at a really
young age and you're like this TR I've
always said this in this
podcast tradition sucks dude
how much bad breath is in there you know
worst music
worst music dude
[Music]
zero handsome people
looks like a scene from E.T for real
it's the grandest
music of all them we hope you had fun on
the Jurassic Park ride exit to your left
such a lull you know
the worst hat a crown is the worst hat
like I I would wear a [__] Fedora
before I would wear a goddamn crown
ah
wow dude this sucks huh like just
straight up
the worst most uncomfortable chair of
all time
I mean can't place it right you know uh
is that good yeah okay man look you look
[__] horrible okay I'm gonna step
back here
so much gold God Save the King
bro it's
2020 [__] [__] sucking three
dude biggest hat of all time
it just goes over his shoulders oh we
needed some oh God we need a smaller one
farting
Star Wars Superman dude
sick
[Music]
I love it dude
uh William Prince of Wales pledged my
loyalty to you and faith and truth I
will bear unto oh damn he's got a good
voice man of life and limb amen help me
God hey man shave it
hey man shave it
Bubba shave it never had a more
perfectly bald just top
than that guy what's his name Prince
Charles
Prince William here hey man shave it
so slow oh now let me put one on you now
I I put a [__] crown on you you're a
you're a queen right yeah there we go
okay something sucks just make sure it's
there and [__] goddamn Trump I'd say
this summer
the King dies and [__]
Brent has to take his place
[Music]
[Applause]
can I be my cat
[Laughter]
this whole thing is a [__] Adam said
Rob Schneider's in the back hey what's
up King just
foreign
[Music]
how many views does this have
183 000 views that's nothing
that that should that that just goes to
show you that it I mean we get more
views on this podcast you know
ah
God Britain people just need to [__]
give it up huh
Give It Up
a giant penis was mowed into the grass
at the site of a carnation party
okay give it up
a huge [__] and balls did really good
too looks really nice
that's so good dude
a neighborhood known for its perfect
Lawns that was due to host this lavish
party to celebrate the Carnation of King
Charles III this weekend has been
vandalized in a rather distinct way
residents of Royal Crescent in bath
England
awoke on Thursday May 4th to find an
enormous penis and balls had been also
the fact that they're saying penis and
not testicles are saying and balls you
know
penis and some [__]
uh I don't know what another slang word
is for [__] penises for balls but
um
and an enormous penis and balls with a
bunch of comment it had been mowed into
the grass on otherwise automatically
maintained lawn that is it didn't splurt
yet but unfortunately visible from
pretty much every house on the street
just in time for the Royals festivities
uh comes located in the balls the local
community has been planning a Georgian
themed event to coincide with Charles
Ascent to the throne and is expected to
go ahead as planned they were ve they're
veiny despite the addition of a new set
of crown jewels to location get it crown
jewels are like balls balls have come in
it anyway Charles was officially
dude it was circumcised so the Johnson
visit the store in the king dude
props to this guy who you know it was
one of those lawnmowers that he sat into
which is so gangster
man that's great
I just I wish they still had it and they
were on the lawn
and they didn't even notice because it
was too big and they couldn't see and
then somebody got like a good year of
blimp thing of it and um they were on
the tip of the penis and we got shots of
the [__] King on the tip of the penis
um
foreign
the weekend doesn't want to be the
weekend anymore so that's cool
uh what's up with bro everyone loses
their mind huh
everyone Puff Daddy was puffy Puff Daddy
then Diddy
Prince was Prince and his artists
formerly known as Prince
the weekend doesn't want to be the
weekend anymore who does it want to be
it
in a new interview with W magazine
musician Abel tesfaye tesfay better
known by his moniker the weekend
weakened hinted at this time
inhabiting that particular pop star
Persona maybe coming to a close
I'm going through a cathartic path right
now hey dude congratulations your 20
year old chick for saying that
um I don't know it's like I'm just going
through a cathartic
um path right now so it's getting to a
place where time where I'm getting ready
to close the weekend chapter I'll still
make music maybe as able maybe as the
weekend but I still want to kill the
weekend and I will eventually I'm
definitely trying to shed the skin and
be reborn hey guy dude you're just a guy
and also let us know when you are going
to do it don't you don't need to [__]
prep us you know hey just so you guys
know I'm gonna be changing my name oh
cool man
it's just like I'm shedding that Persona
the album I'm working on now will
probably be my last Horizon the weekend
I mean seeing so many different things I
might do it I might not do it they sound
probably the last one of the weekend
that'll be able or something else
this is something that I have to do as
the weekend I've said everything I could
say hey dude you're still that guy
wow I love that we could make some good
music right
described his last album in 2022's Dawn
FM is part of a new Trilogy dude that's
what I gotta do man I gotta have a
[__] Trilogy of comedy specials [__]
my new special that's gonna come out
that I shot that's [__] Bonkers best
thing I ever did that's the beginning of
a new Trilogy man or
I don't know man and then I'm gonna call
the my next special whatever the title
is the title and then Reloaded
and then revolutions oh wow that would
be so dope dude and the last special I
wear the [__] long trench coat and
those [__] ass sunglasses that he wears
dude how about the scenes in The Matrix
when he was just like when that when
whenever they want to go see the Oracle
the first one when he sees the Oracle
it's cool and then it got so annoying
it's like you see what you want to see
you're like all right dude I've seen
this 900 times before I saw Twilight
dude I saw Twilight today on the plane
dude I'll tell you one thing about
Twilight man
I gotta hand it to the [__] the way
that they made that movie and it's it's
good and it and it's good and that's it
dude and the acting isn't necessarily
top-notch but it was all the first
things that they did
um movie was entirely too gray
everything in it was gray it was only
Shades of Gray there was no like the
only thing red was the car
uh the the the pickup truck that [__]
uh
whatever her name did
um had in it and uh but I love Robert
Pattinson man I love that guy
um and I know he listens to this podcast
sometimes so hey Rob Pattinson dude
probably didn't listen to it anymore
because um he's Batman but
um
I love Rob Pattinson uh love Taylor
Lautner
uh uh attractive as [__]
um
it was okay you know the movie's good
too Gray
and I should be in it what I don't get
is the [__] the the I watched the
Twilight I watch Twilight and everyone
in it was so pale
and we hung out with them for a while
and then the vampires showed up and then
they were even more pale and it's like
the only I guess the Indian people were
tan right Taylor Lautner he was tan
I gotta be [__] tan dude I'm a bad
color
we watched the movie
um on the plane at the same time and we
text each other
life hack dude
straight up [__] we do that we pick
movies and watch them [__] it and we
text each other while we do it and we
start at the title card and I count down
dude and a countdown from 10 and then we
do it and we touch each other and we
laugh so hard dude
that's so much better than the [__]
King's coronation it's unbelievable it
was so dope uh and it's so funny and we
laughed so hard we talked about how fat
David is and [__] and sometimes and then
David ah who cares dude I'm not talking
about that anymore yes dude I do what I
want
I do what I want dude you should do what
you want to
here we go
Spain's women race women's race
apologizes for food processor non-fat
gifts
people be apologizing for everything
Madrid the organizers of a women's
running race in Spain apologized Monday
after the winner was offered a food
processor to take home sparking
accusations of sexism
the seven kilometer Carrera de la mujer
women's race issued a statement on
Twitter saying it hadn't considered the
kitchen appliance donated by a sponsor
would have sexist implications oh
because they give her a [__] kitchen
appliance dude
dude Spain is so sexist uh
congratulations yes this is great uh
amazing amazing here's an apron [__]
hey you won good job here is a nurse
uniform and [__] clean this room
that's so funny dude that's like you can
totally do that and just think it's nice
and then just we apologize we consider
this product a product with no sexist
character and a deal for any athlete who
wants to improve their nutritional
habits
tits or not what if that's what they
said
the statement said we regret if any
woman felt offended
tits or not
the organizer promised to take measures
to avoid similar incidents in the future
I mean dude I love how they always take
measures like hey we got to take
measures hey just don't do that anymore
that's the only measure you got to take
don't give somebody a [__] blender
after they win a race
that's enough
Serb National Ivana zagorak won the race
in 24 minutes seven seconds Sunday in an
amateur event which
okay
um the food processor controversy went
largely unnoticed until Angela Rodriguez
Pam Spain Secretary of State for
equality tweeted that the winner had
received a food process around others
were given zero percent fat products
dude this is it the snitcher there it is
there's always a snitcher the Angela
Rodriguez hey you need to go it wasn't a
problem until you [__] brought it up
you're snitching
back in 2001 nobody was snitching and
now we got the Secretary of State
Spain's Secretary of State for equality
that's a title the fact that that's even
a thing okay fine whatever I think
everyone should be equal
but dude stop snitching you [__] now
she's shaming them she should be shamed
for snitching
if you win a housewife
if you win housewife and if not at least
you'll lose weight
oh got it
that's what she tweeted the races
previously featured t-shirts with the
slogan today the girls win okay so what
about that tweet about how that's good
huh
where are you now uh Secretary of State
uh for equality
to see what Trump said about the thing
uh
this was this is why people love them
what Trump said about um when in the
deposition
when he was just like Trump
Trump deposition
uh about the uh
this is it now are you familiar with the
woman by the name of Natasha stoinoff
no Natasha smashed her to Oblivion he
goes like this
no
Smasher to Oblivion
starting off
so pissed you'll have to give me a
little bit you remember she wrote you
remember she wrote about you a lot when
she worked at People magazine oh I do
remember there was some woman oh
contempt that wrote and then she
a long time later I think she wrote a
wonderful story
and then a long time
as I remember it a long time later she
said that I was
aggressive with her
but she wrote the most beautiful story
and then all of a sudden like is it a
year or two years later she comes out
with this phony story that I was agreed
I said well why would she have written
such a good story for People magazine
she wrote a really nice piece I agree
and that is odd all of a sudden like uh
you know
years or months many months later
she came up with this phony charge let's
watch a video and again I apologize for
the technology where you talk about
mysterious allegations
remarking this oh boy um we're gonna
mark it it's a clip of a video from a
campaign event in West Palm Beach
on October 13 2016 and we're going to
mark it as djt 36. where's the part
where he does the thing
you know what I'm talking about have you
seen it
no no
hold on then there was a writer
from People magazine oh boy oh boy
yeah oh about to be off the rails on our
first anniversary
the story was beautiful it was
that after 12 years this took place 12
years ago this story
a new claim that I made inappropriate
advances
during the interview to this writer
well I mean dude playing the crowd so
hard
people grabbing [__] while they're
doing no 200
isn't it here 20
20 or 12 years ago why was it a part of
the story why didn't they make it part
of the story
I was one of the biggest stars on
television yeah and it would have been
one of the biggest stories of the Year
think of it she's doing this story on
Melania who's pregnant at the time and
Donald Trump our one year anniversary
said I made inappropriate advances
and by the way the area was a public
area people all over all right let's go
with me that the person you were just
talking about in that video was Natasha
storing off correct yes are you familiar
with a woman by the name of Jessica
Leeds
just no I don't think so explain go
ahead does that mean that this refresh
your recollection yeah this woman made
up a story
just like your client made it up yeah
just made up a story
having to do with sitting me in it
sitting next to me in an airplane era
airplane
and I mean I'll have to read this again
but that story
was so false also
but this was I guess making out as
opposed to
what your client said this story was so
false this is a disgrace also and do you
recall speaking about
Ms Leeds allegations at campaign events
in 2016. I might have I thought it was
so come on where's the part
why do they make it seven minutes
okay
when you said in that video that
that would not be your first here it is
here it is you were referring to her
physical looks correct just the overall
not I I look at her I see her I hear
what she says whatever you wouldn't be a
choice of mine either to be honest with
you I hope you're not insulted I would
not under any circumstances have any
interest in it keeps going keep going
I'm being I'm honest to what I say oh it
doesn't mean you're not a dick
yeah the video we just lost a lot when
you talked about this I just just look
you she's your dog you're a dog you look
like a dog you look a basset hound you
know you look a basset hound and I would
never be into you I don't [__] dogs so
you know
dude that's awesome
this guy
wow what a [__] cray just it's WWE
that's [__] wild
um
oh I saw this dude Hilton Hotel manager
arrested for waking up guests by sucking
on his toes
did you see this did you see this yeah
dude mug shot unreal
hair so bad
here we go Nashville Tennessee dude
let's just play this out
honestly
so
this is what happened a hotel manager
Hotel manager was arrested and charged
Friday for entering a guest room and
sucking on a customer's toes
David Neal 52 was charged in a
aggravated burglar and sulfur all right
suck on his toes so so check it out dude
so this will happen right
[Music]
what oh [__] ah freeze oh [__] dude yo
that is the
worst crime dude
hey dude at least get some money about
out of it yay Dude where's Chrome of all
time walking snuck in suck the guy's
toes dude that
honestly
that's pretty gangster dude I gotta I
gotta I got I know it's assault but it's
that one is the most weirdest gangster
what's up with foot guys huh hey they're
feet
I have a friend who loves foot
uh has a foot fetish dude a very popular
comedian won't expose them but um crazy
loves feet
you know when you when you're on the
porn when you're on the porn sites and
then you see the one thumbnail and the
chicks just like
hey I skipped past that one man
not a foot guy
um
while investigating a complaint officers
discovered that Neil working as a
nightmare at the time made a key card
and entered a guest room this is I don't
understand why uh I've you'd think that
they'd do it more and uh that this would
happen all the time
the guests recognize Neil because the
day before he came into the room with
another employee to fix an issue with
the television on his folks oh dude Neil
claimed that he had entered a room
because he smelled smoke and was
checking on the victim however the night
manager did not report decision security
all right dude and then when I love it
when he's like oh yeah because he walked
in to do the thing
if he walked in to fix the room and then
he was like ah there was a moment where
he was like yeah I'm gonna do that toe
sucker thing this is the guy
um and guess what happened in Tennessee
no [__] uh
oh [__]
27 000 bail for [__] sucking on toes
hey what are you in here for oh I
[__] killed the family what are you
in here for I sucked on a clients I
sucked on a customer's house
um
people are [__] nuts bro
this is why the thing about Trump it's
like people do make [__] up man
like look at this women charged with
faking her own abduction to hide the
fact that she dropped out of college
whoa
is it on
oh no sir
there was a scare that went on through
the entire Community but after more than
20 hours of searching for Chloe Stein
and questions we found out she was just
lazy as [__] included Stein's
disappearance was all a lie that lie
included the report she was a college
senior a detail that can be seen on her
Instagram bio reading PSU 23. one of the
things that came to light while we were
searching for you
was
uh this college thing
this college you your family thinks
you're graduating
on Saturday
that's not happening you know you're not
graduating on Saturday I reached out to
Penn State greater Allegheny this
morning they tell me Stein hasn't been
enrolled at any Penn State campus since
the fall 2018 semester that is one of
the big reasons police changed their
approach to this investigation
I don't know man I believe her I mean
believe all women you know I think that
she was abducted even still
her boyfriend tried to contact her again
and was trying to because he said bro
and this is hilarious but you know women
don't lie so
they didn't rely right and if you say
that then people will just shame you to
Oblivion right
let's say you do violence
um
all right I had to go to the bathroom it
was a little cut there
um
what did you guys do for the fourth May
the fourth be with you may the fourth
beath here's the darkest thing I've ever
heard in my life I think I and it keeps
going and here's the thing about the
fourth be with you thing is
that's just gonna be around for the rest
of my life I'm gonna have to live and
keep being around that
you understand how that happens that
sucks you ever think about that that
you're gonna have to like the fact that
I have to be alive now the whole time in
my life while Kim while the Kardashians
or something
like that's the actual light that's the
era I live in
you know
at least back when there wasn't the
internet or TV like you didn't have to
do that like even around Napoleon times
like Napoleon could be pillaging and
[__] or Genghis Khan could be [__]
coming in and just you know but you just
don't be around that you'd be like I
don't have to really deal with it you
know unless he invades but I'll find a
remote place
and it's like now if you don't like
somebody they're just gonna be on TV the
whole time and even if not you got to
pick up your phone you gotta say [__]
Kardashians I gotta see I gotta see the
latest deals on skims or whatever the
[__] why do I know about Kardashians
[__] Spanx company
I gotta know about skims and I gotta
know about it a healthy amount because
she's so [__] famous dude
I gotta know about this
right
so that's the era I live in and now I
gotta be just hearing about May the
fourth be with you just basically once
per year for the rest of my life I gotta
hear it's gonna be May every May oh for
the rest of my life it's gonna happen
when will that dwindle out right maybe
when Calvin gets to be 80 I'll be long
gone though dude except for maybe
Transcendence will be real or whatever
the [__] you know
um
it's all [__] uh
let's do deserve at scale these are
great just some mild tailgating well let
me know how this is gonna end
road rage oh he [__] smashed him
oh my God
oh
I mean he's just [__] ah and the air
bags went up what a [__] [__] dude
top ten
top ten what a [__] dude just crashing
into him in [__] airbag exploded what
a loser ass [__] [__] yeah dude
love it
oh that one got removed
uh Reddit it's pretty impressive until
it wasn't here we go
oh he's doing calisthenics
on the Jenga Tower well he's gonna [__]
his nose up huh
God damn
Jenga
worst Jenga commercial
[Music]
how did you think it was gonna end
thank God he didn't [__] scorpion it
you know what I mean
bro if I scorpioned I'd be like Oh I'm
dead
right then
that guy didn't scorpion though so
that's okay let's see if I can score
here we go guys at the beach oh I was
gonna kick the football
no
[Music]
oh no
yeah
I mean dude
oh no the [__] ass with the camera too
oh dude I love how in the background it
was just
like it's a [__] car auction
that's not his fault whoever was out
there that sucks
[__] that guy for kicking a football
period
don't ever kick footballs honestly
unless you're one of the Eagles here's
another one here we go I hope they get
hurt hate Partners just kidding
I was gonna go flying off in here oh my
God that's a thing so dangerous
I knew what was gonna happen
oh dude that [__] him up so bad he
turned American
I believe
oh [__] oh [__] oh [__] I mean so
[__] yeah
so French
so French English
real quick
uh
turn American
dude the worst was when the lady goes ah
right when it happens she doesn't even
know [__] how much it hurt
s
oh God you know
oh boy she busted
that guy's got no anus anymore huh it's
all clogged up
I would if that happened to me I would
just choose to die
I would just go like this oh that's it
life
nope that'd be less what was the last
thing you said he goes like this nope
real quick like that
here we go let's look at these uh uh
Tinder shits
great
uh
this person had to send their profile
for approximately 24 hours
they're right I'm scared of you
the other person writes here's the
suggestion I could invite you over to
play with some colorful balls for a
while hit and then afterwards you could
pretend to be my mother and breastfeed
me from your hopefully lactating teats
you know worst part is that he said
teeth alternatively we could
alternatively dude who's this guy Mr and
or uh from uh what do you call it the
Matrix
here's a suggestion
I could invite you over to play with
some colorful balls for a while then
afterwards you can pretend to be my
mother and breastfeed me from your
hopefully lactating teats
alternatively we could find someone weak
to bully wow I mean you know
where I can show you how to make oh
still the guy or I can show you how to
make Exquisite garlic bread and pasta
from scratch wow put the last part in
just in case the teach thing wasn't
going to work out you know foreign
garlic from scratch lead with that um
more of a romantic style date than
sucking from her teeth
um
here we go here's another one uh don't
let your dreams be dreams here we go I
visit last year Safari cool did you like
it yes I got threesome oh dude right to
it sounds good what are you looking for
this time
[Laughter]
he writes foursome wow love it dude love
it this guy's gangster man
uh right to it man that's how your boy
would always do it back when [__] he
was all right well he got in trouble so
um here we go is another one and uh
something tells me she has daddy issues
here we go
uh lawyer daddy issues stop being nice
to me I got daddy issues I'm gonna fall
in love if you're tall I'll love you
Blue Eyes my weakness I want a proud
daddy of me yes
dad died early okay all good all good I
died when you're ready
[Music]
oh
hmm
and she you know starts sucking lots of
[__] that's what happened that's what
happens
let's do misconnections here we go
missing a larger f
just say female I'm
not the part that's going to be weird
you know mid-20s black Polynesian male
511 muscular build DDF I don't know what
that is looking for a thick plus size
lady friend for some activities wow
okay
my flip-flops number 11.
hi I have flip-flops number 11 for you
nice and clean flip-flops like new mail
here
I mean [__] uh
kinky Rain Man
I have flip-flops number 11 for you nice
and clean flip-flops like new mail here
special exercise partner needed Redondo
special wow
could sure stand some exercise
some special exercises what I need how
about you looking for a she type
oh
this is my favorite one of all time dude
CD player needs repair
and then the body of it get the music
playing
people show up looking to suck dicks nah
I just want the [__] thing to be
cleaned out come on
here's not one more thick women at Whole
Foods I was the little guy 50 years old
who picked up the ball pepper the bell
pepper you dropped I wanted to put my
arms around your waist so badly skanky's
specific you have a big butt so shapely
and firm derriere I hope we meet again
ah
hell in a handbasket you know
all right well that's it
chrisley.com if you want to go I'll be
in Nashville I'll be in all sorts of
cities and dates and all that [__] go to
either got the reading date in
Pennsylvania up Philadelphia I got uh
uh Pueblo Colorado for some reason a
little Our Little Rock Arkansas and uh
boys Boise I'll be there uh this week
next week and um
so let's see It'll be there next week
but a bunch of other ones Tucson's
coming up hey that's it for the YouTube
episode if you want the raw the uncut
the unedited the uh you know the
gangbusters episode on patreon go over
to patreon.com crystalia you will get it
all as it's intended not the cut up
version no ads and also you will get
every month we have an episode extra for
the patreon and you will be getting that
every month not only that you will be
getting all the backlogs of the patreon
episodes that we've done there's like
almost 30 of them so go to get them you
could do that right now and it's just
six bucks so check it out and stuff
thank you very much uh leave a comment
[Music]
thank you